one thousand one hundred percent that is
the current increase in border
encounters in just one arizona sector
with sources telling fox news those
encounters could be even higher the
astonishing surge coming as the biden
administration prepares to end major
border policy title 42 but our next
guest has a plan to stop the white house
in its tracks arizona's attorney general
and u.s senate candidate mark bronovich
joins us now good morning mark thank you
ainsley for having me on thanks for
coming on i know you wanted to come on
this morning to announce your plan what
is your plan to stop this from happening
well we just filed a lawsuit we are
filing another lawsuit against the bidet
administration and basically we know
that their attempt to rescind title 42
will lead to drastic um consequences on
our southern border and right now it's
essentially on fire and this will be
like throwing gasoline on a fire so we
want to stop the blind administration
from rescinding title 42 because it may
be one of the most boneheaded decisions
of this administration and they have
done a lot of dumb things but you will
have to find a federal judge who agrees
with you and i'm sure the white house
will appeal what are the chances that
you'll be successful
well i just argued just a little over a
month ago against the biden
administration in court when they
rescinded the public charge rule and
unconfident in that case and i'm
confident we'll win this case because
literally if the biden administration
rescinds this policy it will result in
more than half a million people it's
estimated to illegally cross our border
in just one month that's like the entire
population of baltimore atlanta georgia
so the system is already being
overwhelmed the cartels have seized
control of the border we see a record
amount of fentanyl coming into this
country and now you're going to throw on
top of that hundreds of thousands of
people millions of people just
stretching thin our social and safety
network and endangering our community so
ainsley i'm doing everything i can to
hold the bite administration accountable
and stop them from destroying our
southern border
you know it's it's
what infuriates people is this was put
into place because of covet 19 and now
you're seeing this is lifted for illegal
immigrants yet we still have school kids
ages two to four that have to be wearing
masks in new york city
yeah the the effectlessness and the
hypocrisy of the biden administration
and the progressive left has been on
full display during these coveted
lockdowns where we have seen an attempt
to centralize power in washington dc and
undermine the rights of individuals and
when you look at what's going on in our
southern border that's where the
government has an apex of its power and
they have a constitutional authority
they have a statutory authority to
protect us and they are not doing it and
so whether it's releasing criminals into
our community whether it's not deporting
people deportation orders whether it's a
failure to build the wall we have filed
lawsuits on all of those and we've been
successful and now rescinding title 42
one of the last tools left in the
toolbox that hasn't even overwhelmed us
even more
is just so irresponsible and reckless
and more americans are going to die and
more taxpayers are going to have to pay
for you know everything from health care
to education benefits welfare benefits
as the system gets overwhelmed and so as
our country struggles a lot of middle
class people like myself and our family
you know struggled for to pay for
groceries to pay for gas um we have to
sit there and ask ourselves what is the
biden administration doing because they
are truly undermining and destroying
this country mr attorney general thanks
for coming on
thank you you're welcome hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now